winter is coming everyone is getting
cuffed left and right i think i'm left
out into the frozen desert frozen desert
the frozen desert
yes
yes the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone did we just become best friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sistine and
sophia ooh a little switcheroo well
because i figured since last week i
messed up and didn't i say i owe you and
i figured i think that was two weeks no
last week you're right it was last week
my head is when i mess up the timing
i woke up in a very happy mood today why
good question
sometimes i wake up really sad anyone
else for no reason you know what it is i
feel like most days i do most days i do
and sometimes i'll get a full eight
hours of sleep and i'll be more tired
than i would if i got a three or four
hour sleep really yeah and i had a great
great sleep loss i mean i sweat a little
bit but you know nightmares how is that
possible i make the rooms unbelievably
cold like the opposite she's the one
that sleeps in 75 degrees i'm the one
that likes sleeping like 68 degrees i
think you know it's not even about the
heat i honestly like the pressure of
weight on me as i sleep that's why i
sleep under such heavy blankets yeah
like i almost like to be like suffocated
yeah do you sleep in sweatpants like
what do you sleep in
a hoodie really comforter giant blanket
if i could i'd have a weighted blanket
but i don't i'm literally i'm not going
to say it but i'm the total opposite to
me is like naked on top of the sheets i
changed honestly going with really cold
air on yeah going into the room in the
middle of the night is very scary i'm
like are you having an exorcism like
what are you doing i don't think
actually you get nervous every time you
walk into my room because you don't know
what to expect but it's like weird
because i don't do anything else other
than sophia green's so mad at me
whenever she walks in my room and goes
hey what's up i scream
scream oh god you scared the [ __ ] out of
me and every time i now do it like i
knock on the door i say hello
hello and then i walk in and go hi and
she's still like oh nice i get more
scared of you walking into my room than
i would walking through a haunted house
honestly i jump is it the way i look is
my face scaring you what it is i think i
get so focused when i do my makeup or by
the way i snapped all my makeup today
i put fake eyelashes on and i feel like
i could scale a building i feel like i
could do you always put fake lashes no i
don't normally i've been like oh i saw
one video of this model she's like strip
lashes are out it's all about
individuals i was like she's right the
stranger i've no idea
nope but back on the strip no stripper
better so powerful i always do sharp i
cut my strips in half so i put on the
edge i still think i'm gonna do a makeup
routine one day you should you're good
at makeup i'm scared i thought i'm
hitting mess with makeup i i was
thinking about when we first started
this podcast how we had this
whole outline for the show and we had
all of these segments lined up and one
of them was social media minute and we
were like okay we're gonna do this we're
gonna one minute yeah and just cover all
the things in social media and we kind
of wanted to talk about things that are
involving the media today so yes this is
our social media minute
enter news
anchor
good i saw this on tick tock today
that chris evans is set to do the voice
over for the new buzz lightyear
what
now it wasn't a pixar fan before but i
will as weird as mario being played by
chris pratt
excuse me you know the new mario film
that's coming out how jack black is
playing browser wait but are they doing
an animation like a voiceover or a
voiceover oh i thought they were
dressing up as like no jack black is
bowser honestly i hope he's like that
for halloween that would be be awesome
but chris evans is playing the voice of
i'm not gonna lie i watched the trailer
it's out
sexy really buzzy lightyear is not
allowed to be sexy you thought he looked
sexy well no i didn't think he'd look
sexy because it is a cartoon and that
would be weird
i just have a crush on peter pan
no the real boy
not the cartoon no both
well which cartoon did i really have a
crush on the one from mulan or
ratatouille remy the rat i did not have
a crush on a rat sophia what did you
hear are you kidding me um i remember
his name was like
slater or something like that he was
that
fish with the scar on its eye the one
finding finding nemo okay you think the
cartoon peter pan is weirder than the
cartoon fish from nemo having a crush on
no he's got something i was gonna say i
thought you were gonna say danny phantom
oh yeah he's cute too he was cute
another thing on the social media minute
is uh our producers had sent us this
link this morning
and it honestly triggered me right when
i saw it this is the most disappointing
news i've heard in a while yeah so
apparently
our beloved dating app hinge which
sophia and i
are oh too familiar with uh a little bit
are now
showing this new feature
about
sending voice notes
and
you know we've we've brought this up
before we have a big passion and hatred
towards men sending voice memos i don't
mind my girlfriends doing it if they're
in the car
maybe if you're dating the guy it's fine
i think we went on a rant maybe episode
49 yeah
something like that but when it's a new
thing i don't know i'll give you guys
this is a
quote from their website right so dating
app hinge is adding new audio features
letting users answer the quote getting
to know you
prompts on their profile using audio
clips
and exchange for voice notes so
oh wait actually that kind of sounds
cool
you know no
no sophia if they're answering the
questions because if you don't know what
hinges you answer three very random
questions like my favorite adventure
there's something about though listening
to someone's voice and not actually
seeing
them say it themselves like that's just
weird you're looking at a photo and
you're saying this is what this person
sounds like and you know well obviously
you look at someone's picture on
instagram like oh they're cute you never
think what does their voice sound like i
don't want to know what if
what if you heard their voice before and
you realize you weren't attracted to
their voice and then that's my exact
point that's what i'm saying so then he
just got rid of one guy that you thought
you thought was cute you heard his voice
it sounded not well listen if you're not
attracted to his voice that's a problem
it's a huge red flag
so we'll see how this works out i'm
actually very curious um if anyone is on
hinge you know what i want to see how
this goes if i was on hinge oh man this
would be so funny every answer you
should put it into some sort of
uh voice altering generator and every
single one one will sound like darth
vader and one will sound super high
pitched on helium and so they'll never
know what you do that reminds me of the
tv show on netflix the one with the
masks on so you don't really know what
they look like until the end yes what's
it called um
no not that's the singing one the dating
one that we think is the funnest show
ever uh
beast
dating beasts there's a fantastic beast
something like that where you wear a
mask but regardless it's when you find
out at the end what they actually look
like because they're masked the entire
time i i want someone to do it in a
different language how funny would that
be that would just not make any sense
because i would not know that's
funny that's why it's funny well
speaking of hinge i had said to sistine
that we if you guys followed us before
we went into hot girl summer saying it's
toxic girl summer we were making jokes a
lot saying that we want chaos we want
drama
we did manifest that into our lives and
that was just something we decided two
episodes after that that we didn't it
was too much for me it was too much i
thought it was about that life it wasn't
the life we wanted it wasn't the life
meant for us but
now it's
fall it's going to be winter soon so i
like to call it wifed up winter we are
entertaining winter wifed up winter
winter is coming everyone is getting
cuffed left and right i think i'm left
out into the frozen desert the frozen
desert the frozen desert
yes yes let that sit i meant the frozen
wasteland of winter wonderland just
leave me there single and alone but
she's a white walker out there i am a
white walker out there i'm basically jon
snow no
basically you know nothing jon it's very
interesting why do you think everyone
wants to get wifed up because it's cold
you think that is literally the only
reason it's cold and there's nothing
better
than snuggling someone when it's cold
outside and watching cozy movies and i
think all of the holidays stacked up as
well it's nice to spend with someone
like you got thanksgiving and then you
got christmas and then you have new
year's and then you have valentine's day
and then you'll see paddy's day and then
you have
halloween again it's just
halloween all over no way so you're
having like a cuffed whole year is what
we need yeah cuffed a year but yeah i
agree yeah the temperature goes down
everyone wants to watch the holiday 12
times
you want to have some mulled wine don't
love that movie
so why does everyone like that movie so
much
but what is
what someone love actually i i actually
don't love that one either he's a little
over-hyped i agree with him but i love
the holiday how do you not like cameron
diaz jack black kate winslet
i'm forgetting one great actor he's
really cute i like jack skellington
nightmare before christmas that kind of
holiday that is the scariest film one of
the scariest films i've seen does that
count as a christmas movie i think it
does no it's kind of actually it's kind
of tail it's perfect for you because
it's partially halloween and that's your
favorite holiday and mixed with
christmas i know i know i don't get it
yeah so anyway i agree i think people
like to spend you know what it is no i
think christmas movies really
set people up for failure
created unrealistic expectations that
you're going to have a meet cute with
someone at a toy store and you're both
reaching for the last gift and then it
breaks and you're like oh [ __ ] that's
why we should go get a hot chocolate
i've been reading way too many romance
books and all of them involve meat cutes
and they're so adorable like the front
cover is like two cartoon like obviously
characters kissing and i'm sitting here
like
i can't even get a coffee that's why i
don't really feel bad for you sophia
like you should just do what i do
don't read and then you won't get you
okay so
i'll shut down my entire entire love and
uh favorite book club
do you want to be
wifed up this winter yeah i want to
wifed up winter are you ready for a
relationship it's been over two years
yes
my fingers are getting a little
frostbitten you know what's interesting
i um was watching this interview with
barb of halvin maybe it came out two
years ago this is i think
right when she started dating dylan
sprouse and she was saying she's
such a hot couple but she is so stunning
yeah there's no way this girl doesn't
have a boyfriend all the time she's so
beautiful
she was saying that she was single for
five years
and she thought that there was no guy
for her and it never worked out and she
always thought it was me and she was
just comfortable with the idea of not
being with anyone yeah and then she said
out of nowhere five years later she met
the perfect guy and she said it was
worth the wait so yeah
i've been saying this like i'm putting
0-0 effort in like i'm not even trying i
assume everyone isn't interested and now
i'm kind of getting that maybe i should
i don't know sophia you say you don't
try but yet you tell yourself every day
i don't chase i attract what will come
to you i don't i haven't said that
anymore
i don't chase i attract with belongs
it's not just about love it's about
everything else and you know it was
funny i thought about cuffing season
because christine and i went to lunch
and we sat next to a couple that was on
their first date and i forgot how
awkward first there are so every time i
go to a restaurant now
everyone is on a date everyone literally
only tables for two that's it or three
if they want to have fun like mostly two
stock em in a row because people just
expect it's gonna be a date yeah and so
sofia actually we were on a little date
the other day
and
right next to us was this uh was this
couple and the girl sat down first and
you can tell she was nervous and dressed
up and you could tell she was waiting
for someone and then this guy kind of
shuffles in 10 minutes later and we're
like
and we are listening to their yeah
entire conversation
and that's bad that's bad
don't don't eavesdrop i think that's
total invasion of privacy but let me
tell you when we have like gone on way
too many lunch dates ourselves so we
were curious it's about how you look at
it see
people could say that's very
disrespectful to us drop yes
but
they should put into consideration that
is simply for the listeners we're doing
it for you guys we're
you know observing reporting so that's
what we did i didn't like her outfit
that much that's another red flag oh
sophia right now looks fine oh yeah this
is what she told me she goes she wore an
apple watch what's wrong with an apple i
like apple watches i'm not saying
they're bad but i wouldn't wear it on a
date what am i talking my calorie count
like
but i don't want to see like a text what
if she's doing her steps i have a
question this is it so you know how it's
very rude and this is why it says red
flag you know it's very rude for anybody
on a date to have their phone out right
like you shouldn't check text messages
you shouldn't answer the phone it's
really disrespectful to not focus on
who's in front of you
don't you think that's considered the
same thing when you wear an apple watch
and you're getting text notifications on
your wrist and tell me there is not one
inch like ounce of you that wouldn't
look that's true it's like a reflex it's
your phone and i think also i'm sorry
it's not that stylish so it's like it
doesn't feel like they should upgrade it
i don't think it looks like i don't know
it looks like you're in uh
like spacex you're about to go apples
let's face it it's not that cool but she
wore it and i was like
no i totally agree i didn't think about
it like that because nothing bothers me
more when there is a phone on the table
during dinner
just like just no right no phones you
don't need no watches you know the
[ __ ] sports game right now i know
what's [ __ ] next an apple ring like i
don't need anymore
like any more notifications because my
girlfriend has an apple watch and
constantly her wrist is like popping off
like yeah she just always looks at
messages and i just think that's right
okay so apple watch red flag for sophia
um it sounded like they had met through
a mutual friend
and so all they did was talk about that
friend the friend the entire time they
did talk about they were both in
different medical fields
yeah
but i could just tell there wasn't it
wasn't vibing it wasn't working
something wasn't clicking i don't think
i don't think they were attracted to you
i think there wasn't like a she was more
attracted to him
yeah i don't know no he was dressed nice
he was dressed nice yes he put an outfit
i saw the shoes looked cool the outfit
looked nice it was like a afternoon date
sometimes i think though because like
watching it from you know a fly on the
walls point of view yeah it was very
awkward and sometimes i think
am i that awkward maybe
i don't think you are sophia but we
don't shut up on a date
so that's pretty awkward we don't let
dry space like dry air go no and then we
don't know if the guy actually has any
personality or not after the fifth date
and then we realize they have none and
then we have to formulate a reason i'm
trying to think of the most awkward date
that i've ever been on
so many oh i've i remember one i was on
a date where
you remember the guy you told me i
shouldn't go on a date with him which
one it was the one that he made me drive
50 minutes to the restaurant
because he
it was just about like like i don't mind
driving 50 minutes to a restaurant i
mean
sophia well we both live kind of in the
same area i'll tell you what on a first
date he wanted to bring you to some
suspicious warehouse downtown to check
out his hoodies and i said sophia
i think he was dating someone at that
time i told you which i thought was kind
of wrong
kinda like a little bit i didn't find
out until later and then a year later
obviously he had to be single if he was
asking me out and it was just an awkward
date because i think he was just
starting to do a podcast and we were on
our i think
i don't know maybe it was like 30th
where we've been doing it for so long
yeah and i was trying to give him advice
and he kept
retracting it and so i said to him oh
man he can't take advice from you
i said what you have no balls
oh my god sophia jesus and i kid you not
and by the way when i get you can ask
this when i give advice or if i am
speaking up about something
i am a very harsh
person like i don't like to beat around
the bush i'll tell you as it is and yes
i don't feel this don't forget
personally of caring for you is very
aggressive yeah it comes off as harsh
but it's love i'm a passionate person
every single way especially with
giving advice and so when i said that to
him i didn't mean it literally like i
didn't obviously think that he was like
sounds really gross but i remember the
rest of the day
so uncomfortable like we're at a pasta
place he ordered a salad i'm like oh
you're on a health diet like what are
you like trying to like look he goes
yeah you are busting balls out here
right he goes jesus then he goes yes um
he goes yeah i'm actually trying to like
uh get fit i'm like but who cares oh no
and then i said oh that's fine but i
didn't why did you say anything in the
first place i think i was so nervous for
the date that i just kept mumbling and
jittering anything and
yeah i mean a lot of people do that but
what i have
found that kind of works and is a good
way to
fill up
you know the dead air space and you
don't want to keep talking about
yourself or asking them questions
a little trick that i like to do on a
first or second or whatever date is i'll
look at um
the
the tables around me and i'll make up
scenarios with the date about what
they're meeting about and then
so for example i started like oh my god
you see these two women to my right and
he'll go yeah and i'm like can you
believe
that after
being distant sisters their entire life
they finally are brought back together
based off of like both reaching for the
same coffee at starbucks and he's like
yeah that's insane and then you just
keep building and building and then it
creates well some people are bad at that
and you can tell when someone's about it
they're like oh yeah haha and they don't
continue it and then you keep going and
just i force it out of them you force it
out
yeah that's that's a good date i mean
that's not awkward that's good that you
always have a way to like i'm so good at
dating i know
good i get giddy and nervous and i talk
a lot definitely um oh my god i don't
think i'm bad today i just think that
one specific was bad well i certainly
would not want to go on a first date
with you
why wouldn't you want to date me you
can't just say oh i would never date you
because you would let me talk
that's fair yeah that's it that's her
and i like to talk too well i want to
date you
fair
i remember in high school though we had
this uh news tv show where every friday
they put the the school news or whatever
and there's one segment where this kid
would go around campus
and um
hold up a poster board of all of these
uh yearbook photos and
random students would have to pair who
they think the couple is
and uh
people point to my photo and said no no
she's not dating anyone she's dating
herself
oh i do remember that i'm glad i was so
triggered by it i thought it was funny
but i got called in to the principal
about it
they're asking like are you okay or
you're feeling sorry i can't believe
they aired it's not definitely not a
nice thing but obviously you make a joke
out of it because we were raised with a
dad that like i thought it was funny yes
i am dating myself
so you know how you said in the morning
that you had a really great morning yes
i did too because i actually found a
really good tv series and i know that
you've been wanting to watch it yes it's
the sex loving goop series on netflix
gwyneth paltrow can do no wrong no i i
love group i know people are always
skeptical about her and her message and
all this stuff in goop i don't know why
what what are they skeptical i think
they don't i think people just don't
like her in some ways i don't know what
it is but i really like the show and of
course like the the show was
basically about sex like the first
episode was called a show about sex and
i wasn't really to the point yeah i
wasn't really knowing what to expect
because i knew going into it
maybe it's obviously about sex but about
i don't know if it was about
masturbating and things like that
but it was really interesting because i
know how much we love to talk about five
languages love
yes i'm obsessed with that quiz yeah
it's so much fun if you don't know what
it is take the test it's the way you
respond to love the best like if you
respond with words or touch or gifts
whatever there's five of them and you
should learn yours and your partners but
there was one that was called the
erotic blueprint
yeah so sophia
sends me a link at 9am this morning i
wanted you to take this quiz right now
yeah right i said i'm on it well right
when i saw them doing it i'm like i
gotta just take this while i'm watching
the show
and it was so interesting because
there's five different ones so just like
the five languages love there's five
different erotic blueprints which is
basically
what gets you the most aroused because
everyone has different things that they
like and you do and so is your boyfriend
and your friend and your mom and your
dad whatever sorry not to bring your
parents into this but there's five and
your dog
and your dog and a hamster
yes yes so there's five there's
energetic there's sensual sexual kinky
and shapeshifter so to give that's the
one i want i know what does that mean
i'll explain it so energetic if you're
energetic
space longing presence eye gazing it's
light or hovering touch they feel
more with less touch it's more like
tantra yoga meditation oh it's one of
those people that you can just hover
your hands over there to have like a
full body workout connection intimacy
yeah i knew i wasn't that off the bat
two there's sensual there's pleasures of
all senses so you need the music the
surroundings the textures the oils water
flowers the ambiance that's a lot of
work it's just no it's not it's not that
necessarily it's more
your mind needs to be in it
your space needs to be yes in it so you
can mentally exactly depending on yeah
so then sexual is honestly kind of like
the most generic one which is just like
porn gets you aroused and
naked bodies like things like that it's
easy super to please whatever
kinky
is naughty taboo forbidden playfulness
it's uh you know
it's almost you can use handcuffs you
can use feathers it says it all in the
name yeah yeah it's all like kind of
bdsm a little bit and then shape shifter
is oh so basically you're not one you're
you're two or more like think you're not
just one gets you aroused most of them
do so um you do have it just like uh
five languages of love you have
percentages so you could be
like
a top with one in the second with
another one and something's gonna be
last so i made sistine take it i took it
um i kind of wasn't surprised i got
sensual which is like the surroundings
what you said was
wait you got sensual yes and you were
like you just [ __ ] on that one only oh
sophia i didn't know you needed candles
and no i don't eat candles lavender oil
oh
just in general i like things to be
perfect for over the scenario you have
to manifest
you know the experience to be good
before that jesus all right what is
yours
oh god i think you could probably guess
i'm assuming it's kinky
that would be correct congratulations
oh that's fine but it's actually really
interesting i was shocked by that i
wasn't
excuse me
compliments it means you're exciting
you're different your book is the dare
i'm forbidden you're forbidden fruit no
but it's kind of it was really
interesting watching the show i know
some of you are probably cringing at
this if you don't usually talk about sex
but you know i think it's important to
talk about the couples well were totally
different like the guy was more sexual
the girl was more
uh kinky and he was last on kiki and she
was first on it so i think that's so
important yeah to find that out and so
what happened was
you just saw them learn what each
other's
preferences were and they were able to
do it and it was like the guy started
crying see okay for all unwax listeners
out there please make your partner
take this quiz and then let us know both
of your we're not going to share it on
the show but i'm actually just want to
dm us i'm really curious to see yeah
actually it's called erotic blueprint
there's a cheap um not cheap one this
free one there's another one that's deep
and it's like 17 bucks just do the free
one free one and let us know what you
and your partner scored because i want
to see surprise yeah like opposites
attract yeah and i think if you're both
kinky or you're both
shape shifters which still sounds
awesome and it sounds like a superpower
it sounds so cool it's like i'm going to
be the hulk today
i'd be the hulk in bed and then i'm
going to be the little flower
i'm passionate about the test for you
guys yes okay when you were taking the
test yes did you feel like you had a
hard time answering some of the
questions that you hadn't tried before
like
personally i've never used flips and
chains right yeah how do i know if i'm
kinky if i've never used them right
there so that's the thing there was
questions about that and i relate to
that i just try to picture myself in
this scenario because i felt weird
answering those questions but i haven't
done that that that or if you've seen it
before say if you've seen you know 365
days or 50 shades of grey and that stuff
doesn't make you uncomfortable and
you're like oh wow that seems awesome or
instead you're like covering your eyes
saying oh god right
right i think that's how you would know
right right i mean i'm down to try but
like do i know if i'm gonna be like
being paddled see that's the thing
because how would you actually once
you're in the scenario it can be
completely different you're like
assuming that your interest levels to
kinkiness do you know what i mean
because like a paddle doesn't sound so
appealing to me no but on the show but
like
a handcuffed shore but like yeah
so on the show what they did for her
because she had that same one they just
used feathers they just did more touches
and uh telling her like
feel your shoulder feel your leg
tickling would just be nice
and things like that it didn't have to
be like because like a blindfold because
when you think kink you think like oh
it's going to be 50 shades of grey but
that's not the yeah yeah it's not that
way we have like a stereotype around it
it's not it's it's like it's otherwise
it's way more yeah it gives you those
like little roller things it doesn't
need to be like insane okay also how do
i get a guy to take me with feathers oh
my god i know i i feel like you
introduce it if you don't unless you
make your partner take the test with you
no no no i mean
i don't know the only advice that is
correct here is you have to communicate
but sometimes there's nothing worse than
telling them exactly what you want
because it's just uncomfortable talking
about sex
with your partner is like it could be
weird but
honestly every time you do it's better
like there's never a scenario where it
gets worse tell me one scenario in any
dating
relationship you've ever had that the
number one thing to do is communicate
[Applause]
communicate when you're going through
different types of sex and like life and
communicate when you're going through
anything mental health communicate so
it's what's so true just communicating i
mean look
if you're telling your partner
babe what you're doing
you're a rock star solid i'm gonna give
you an eight out of ten maybe you don't
say that i'm gonna give you
you know pat on the back it's really
good
but
it would feel even better if you did
this
and then you say now what can i do to
make you feel like what can i do better
right and then that way he doesn't feel
like or or she doesn't feel like it's
too much for for them and like they
think they have the responsibility and
so it's even playing field compliment
sandwich yeah always so if you're ever
uncomfortable i don't really know how to
approach sex i actually think this is a
really good show for you to watch and
it's a good introduction so you can do
it by yourself no one needs to know and
then you get more comfortable with it
compliment sex witch
sex witch sandwich
switch yes happy whatever halloween
you know what i've been doing a lot
recently
i spend an extra 20 minutes after i park
just sitting in my car
hmm
is that a form of being sad
huh or i just like being alone i don't
know why i just sometimes i just like to
sit there and just and do nothing and i
feel like i can be alone and i'm safe in
this little bubble i'm just on my phone
i don't know i love it i actually don't
blame you because i did that the other
day when i was just saying that i didn't
want to get out of my car yet i didn't
either i wasn't ready why do you think
that is though i don't know maybe it's
the new shower thought you know
sometimes i feel like i get all of my
thinking done i wrote half of this
episode while just sitting in my car i
just feel like my brain can be clear and
i don't have any you know distractions
because when you live with roommates and
you're you're always out and you're
running around it's nice to do
absolutely nothing and see no one and
talk to you yeah you know what it is
though it's because even if we're in the
same building and you're in different
rooms they're still there it's rare to
have that privacy with whether you're
working on because you work out in the
gym like i do my boxing he goes ryan
goes to work and he has his job with all
of his co-workers even coming back we
still are around each other sometimes i
think your body it's like it's a natural
way of saying
i need
zero people zero people like any talk be
alone it's always safe it's only space
because there's no person that can knock
on your win i mean yes they can but like
i think where you were parking
definitely no one does that i know i i
realize how important it is to actually
take time for yourself
because i always thought oh i love being
around people and i love living with
people and i love always talking to
people and going to dinner with people
but actually being alone
is
awesome
and i really need to start doing it more
and it's honestly helped my brain sort
of calm down i think i run
on a low level of anxiety all day but
then don't realize it because i'm
undiagnosed so i'm always just a little
bit i think we've diagnosed it are you
allowed to diagnose it though
yeah don't i need a therapist for that i
think i've gone through enough
therapists okay i'm talking about it i'm
gonna diagnose her yeah but um
yeah no i feel like i'm constantly just
like always on the verge like always on
the edge to be like
it could go bad or you've seen that tick
tock right now like
turn it to the
so so
it's almost my form of meditation
because i don't spend those 20 30
minutes in the morning like that's my
way of doing it and then i'm able to
come out of the car relaxed calm
well you know it's also good and it's
i think it's important to also if you
live with a roommate you love your
boyfriend whoever girlfriend um parents
is when you are with people 24 7 those
people can really irritate you and i
know that sistine and i like we we've
said this before we work eat sleep
basically do everything together like
we're pretty codependent we're very
co-dependent on each other like honestly
she as much as we should on each other
on this podcast like i can't live
without her she i hope you can't live
with no it's true though yeah like we go
to each other for any advice for any
like makeup help hairstyles
like we're very co-dependent and we
really we try to act to not like we're
not no that's what's so funny it's like
our opinions are so polar opposite the
way we execute anything is so different
but we're so dependent on each other
yeah we'll never admit
that like i need you when you need me
for anything no because it's funny that
the other day um they're like it felt a
little off and it just gave us both like
even though we didn't bring it up so
much anxiety that by the end of the day
i think she was leaving she's like are
you mad at me i walk into your room i
was like
like that kid you know the kid meme
where it's standing at the end of your
parents bed being like i threw up like
that and honestly if he was lying about
i'm like standing over here
are you mad at me or something and i was
like honestly i wasn't mad at you i
think i was frustrated about something
before but i really wasn't upset but
even that like we just we're so
dependent on each other we know even a
slight inkling but then that the problem
with that is that we take on each
other's energies and that happens a lot
when you're living with someone
constantly is that you if you're feeling
off i can feel it if i'm feeling off you
can feel it and so it's not only that
you're dealing with your own emotions
you're dealing with mine as well
so
like i mean going into taking time for
yourself the car thing
i know i i just uh
sometimes i wonder
and this has nothing to do with you
obviously but sometimes i wonder i'm
like what would would it be
easier if like i had no roommates at all
and i don't know if it would be
i just think maybe
you know finding things that are totally
separate from
i don't know maybe i need a hobby or
something
i think that's what i need to start i
need a hobby i think you're
she is really you're i know you this
sounds weird but like your gym sessions
your your workouts yeah but that's like
no but i'm out of my entire day no i get
it i get it but that is like she writes
down her own routines you've studied
weightlifting you've studied all this
stuff like you actually she prioritizes
it makes it a thing you know you don't
call it a hobby but it kind of is in
some ways because you've actually you
could literally create a workout
schedule for someone and two you've done
it for scar like eight times i didn't
actually send her one yesterday that
sounds exactly that is a hobby but that
is taking time for yourself but no i
don't i need to do something at night
where it's like
a wine and painting class
you know every tuesday you know what i
did that i loved doing and we were
saying this like night workouts and
things like that are so good but when i
used to go to these um meditation
classes and it would be like at six
o'clock at night and they're an hour and
you just do not talk and you're just
meditating driving home during sunset no
one looking at you no one talking to you
is so nice no that already gives me so
much anxiety for multiple reasons one
sitting still for an hour can't do it
two
when it's not quiet no when it's that
quiet i get worried about noises that
come out of my body like am i breathing
too loud do they hear me they do my
stomach growls at insane that's
happening to me actually whenever it's
quiet right it does grow my stomach is
like on x games mode all the time yeah
especially
at night like i always have to crack my
back what if you have to like fart like
literally so many things yeah well but
also back to when you're saying like
would it be better to live alone
um i think the only thing i'd be worried
about is like am i going to be more
separated from my friends and family
like because because when we're those
people that if you don't get us out of
our zone we can stay in our company i
don't think that's the case no i think
it's the opposite if you're living alone
you'll force yourself to go out more to
see your friends whereas if you're
already living with your friends you're
comfortable always staying home mm-hmm
what if no i don't because what if your
friend is saying let's go out you look
at them they're like the same dinner
every night of the week at the same time
with the same sriracha with the same
sliced carrot it's like the same thing
what are you saying parade cauliflower
we do not get out of our our routine no
we do we're good at it we make sure we
do honestly coming and shooting this
podcast is my highlight i'm like woo
change people getting ready no but you
know
in the end i think it is really
important to take your separation and
sitting in the car maybe is your body's
way of saying i need some time i love it
i listen to podcasts in the car that's
great it's so great you know we're not
or we're not going to get some time very
soon though because we're about to visit
our whole family in florida hey yeah i'm
excited i know i love florida i miss
scarlett a lot yeah we haven't seen her
since she's left i know i wonder what
she's going to look like i have no i
feel like she's going to look different
seriously she's super blonde you you
always look different like when you come
back from your freshman year of college
yeah i look totally something happens
people change yeah i i didn't look too
good what if i don't
what if i was like who are you i know
she what if she's what if she's sassier
than she is now because she thinks that
she knows a lot more because she's like
a college student you know she probably
does more no more than me though yeah i
know she's way cooler than we were in
freshman year of college no but i'm
excited to see mom and dad and yeah
they're absolutely tweaking with
excitement to see us i know the only
pain in the ass is the flight i hate
flying
five out i hate planes not that i'm
scared of planes but does anyone else
feel like [ __ ] on and off a flight like
i get so dehydrated no matter if i buy
four liters of water i look horrible i
don't like it i just that is jet lag my
biggest fear about traveling with
a potential partner in the future
if they say babe we're gonna go to
montana i don't know yeah vegas but sure
that's a better one vegas why would we
go to montana
uh
yeah i would say
sounds good
i'm going to fly a day early and meet
you there because i don't want you to
see what i look like coming on the plane
especially coming off the plane because
for some reason i get like seven new
pimples by the time we launch literally
what the [ __ ] up with that i'm not
gonna be that girl that puts on a face
mask in the middle of a flight like a
jelly mask like i don't want to look
like what's it called but then like
myers like if i'm i'm you know if i'm
traveling i gotta put some concealer on
and brush the brows up but then oil
how are you i don't think i've ever
looked good
leaving a flight no never i really am on
it and i smell it so here's the thing so
bad
gross
not only that when we were flying i
think back from seeing our parents you
were trying to watch a movie and i've
had this thought
what answer me this question ready
what do you do when you're watching a
sex scene on a flight
seriously or any type of risque film i
only watch risque films so
do you i have i always get so nervous i
cover this screen and i look so awkward
it's my favorite pastime to make people
uncomfortable i love it what was the
last one i watched i did magic mike
actually
and i like two flights ago yeah and then
oh disobedience
oh yeah what
i watched a movie called disobedience on
a flight and i was like this seems
appropriate right now i feel like i for
oh god there was also a film i watched
that had some like
sexual scenes in it and i get so i just
don't like making other people feel
uncomfortable because they're not
choosing to watch the film well you just
choosing to look at your screen and say
what's up what's up
oh god i don't know well let's test this
theory
the flight there you watch the film tell
me how it goes be very blatantly obvious
that you're watching it i'm gonna look
around be like you guys see this you
guys want to watch this with me anyone
else want to share a headphone no oh god
i honestly wish that people were more
communicative on flights
i love talking to people i know you do
like to message people you guys i had a
crazy experience one time i thought i
met the love of my life on a plane
actually though i actually facetimed me
the moment she got off the plane because
of this no i honestly thought i this is
my new boyfriend
if you're watching this this is so
embarrassing it's definitely not what's
up uh yeah yeah i honestly did and i
could not have looked worse for a flight
in my life i was on my way to puerto
rico
about to play a prostitute this is a
true story
my hair was bright orange
because i dyed it very wrong and i had a
hood on that was so big it looked like
the grim reaper and i made sure it
purposely covered half my face because i
was looking extra ugly this morning
and uh
i so i remember my head was down and i
was listening to billy eilish to get sad
so she likes to make herself sad
listening to sad songs it's my favorite
yeah i'm really late i am
and i look to my left and i look down at
his feet and i'm like oh
there's some nice shoes
and then i trail off them only i like
those pants and then i'm like oh my god
he's wearing
one of those
you know
camel colored trench coats with a gray
hoodie are you kidding me right now bro
and i looked like this that's nice
actually and i looked like this i'm
pretty sure there was a stand on the
hoodie it was so bad
and he says something he goes oh oh god
maybe i'm bad today because this is a
terrible line he goes
oh i like your bag
i had a really cool backpack
and i go thanks i could fit my whole
closet in it
why would i say that news why would i
say that i don't know i actually don't
know four hours later we're still
talking yeah and it went great it did go
great and we went on a date dana went
home yeah i know they went on two dates
and the second date was atrocious
atrocious i feel bad i really not not
that like whatever but i really wanted
that to work because i loved the build
build-up of it commuting
i know
it's just like how cute is that it
honestly was the greatest round trip of
my life because i met this guy on the
way there and on the way home i sat next
to a practicing witch oh yeah
i know guess what my luck is amazing so
funny oh get this this lady's crazy so
she's pounding chardonnays i think she's
on her seventh one and so she starts
talking talking talking and it was much
better than what i was watching on the
tv so i of course i'm engaging and i'm
egging her on because it's just fun
and she starts to talk telling me about
how she was an actor and that she's you
know in musicals and theaters and she
starts giving me
an entire monologue from the talented mr
ripley but she's playing all three
characters with different voices it's
amazing and then she uh
she notices that i get nervous this is
when it gets interesting she notices
that i get nervous when there's
turbulence i clutch my seat and i'm you
do you know stretched it was it was um
it was bad it wasn't like it was like
it was a pretty big one
and she leans over and she goes don't
worry you're not dying on this flight
oh it gets better i go
how do you
know
and she goes
because i know how you're going to die
and i said
do tell
i feel like most people at this point
would say abort i'm not
of course i want to know what this girl
on her now ninth chardonnay
has for me cause she's definitely sounds
like the word of wisdom i think so she
looked like a little witchy you know
so
i said tell me and she goes look i don't
want to freak you out
but i'm a practicing witch for the last
19 years
and i know how everyone's gonna die but
i'm just telling you right now you're
not gonna die on this plane and i said
will you tell me how i'm gonna die and
she said no but you will live a very
long life but i do need to warn you you
have a terrible relationship with your
mother and you need to fix it and i was
like
i have a great relationship yeah
mom and you are like best friends you're
actually more alike than mom and dad but
anyway i thought it was so funny i was
late and i was like yeah we do yep
uh-huh so what do i it was so funny she
was just telling me everything she tells
me about my dating life and she was she
write about she was wrong
everything i would have loved to hear
what her idea of like but i was agreeing
with all of it you know what i just
remembered that cysteine has a natural
ability to bring in psychics or witches
around her like little we'll be out in a
restaurant and some lady will come up
it's one of those moments i get so
jealous i want those moments so good
where the lady goes
i have to tell you something lis this is
so crazy and she goes what i was that
dinner with my family and my then my now
ex right so we were dating at the time
this woman
pulls me i was the last one in line as
we're all leaving pulls me out of the
group she goes i'm so sorry i never do
this but something was telling me that i
need to tell you this
the person that you're seeing now is not
gonna last he's not good for you and
something very bad can happen soon
i go
oh my god right chills
she was right
something bad did happen to him but he's
okay now but like no no it was
i even told the guy i was like how crazy
is that i thought it was yeah
crazy
we go on a trip all hell breaks lose oh
my god that's
oh my god now everything's coming back
yeah
it's so true maybe psychics love me no
because
the second came on so that you have like
a natural ability to bring in that type
of thing to tell you guys well aura is
pretty good i don't know
you're so annoying okay
so you guys you know we love our
unsolicited advice and we love when you
guys write in so just a friendly
reminder because we love hearing from
you go to apple podcast on wax podcast
give this a 5 stars and ask your
questions there we check all the time so
we're definitely looking for those
really good questions yes also i was
reading a lot of the youtube comments
this morning on multiple videos of ours
and they're all very positive so thank
you guys so much for commenting and
writing in i do not lie we read all of
them so thank you guys we really really
really really appreciate it so this one
um i can't really pronounce the name but
regardless um this show goes great with
a nice sandwich from calabrias yes it
does i would love to try that solid
point would be better um with all three
sisters
i agree i agree i like the banter also
the show is off the cuff no stiff fake
stuff like lots of other media yes this
show is very much
off the cuff
to say well you're on wax so speaking of
stiff what's sophia's idea of a great
romantic weekend getaway be specific
right down to the type of wine this
listener really knows sofia well if he's
asking or she
right down to the type of wine because
sophia would already have yeah picked
out i would okay for one thing
i don't like flights as i said i think i
look bad my whole body's dehydrated
so um
we're driving somewhere so if i if i'm
in la i'd say let's go to santa barbara
for the weekend oh cute right get a cute
hotel get a cute little ocean view
mm-hmm a cute restaurant
um i'm trying to think about the wine i
would probably have red or white
i love both way white
don't sleep on avaline by cameron diaz
that white wine is fire it's so good for
you everyone get it so good so good um
red i like a pinot noir okay so what are
you ordering are we carving out are we
doing a little we're definitely carving
it out i'm not gonna be that girl that's
well if it's a fish please or salmon or
the soul if it's a possibilities we're
getting the not red sauce because that
makes my tummy hurt she's like we'll get
like a little
uh
de pepe whatever that one's called
pepper i switch it up we can get away
here it goes you fly me
to vegas
you fly me to tokyo for the weekend
you said you don't want any flights no
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
we're gonna go balls to the wall you're
getting a private jet we're going to
tokyo and guess what we're doing in
tokyo we're going to do some karaoke in
tokyo it's definitely like lost in
translation i want the pink wig without
the depression yes without the
depression and the champagne so we're
drunk and we're happy and we're singing
we're there for the weekend we go to
that top floor that's really sexy at the
hotel that we were we stayed at one time
i don't know i don't know but we're
walking around they have the best
nightclubs there go to a nightclub we
get back and he's like baby we're going
home and the rest of time i get a
massage on the flight
she's like the rest of the time we are
shape-shifting yes
you know what why we have avalon
see of avalon right does he have any
like flowers for you at the room maybe
some chocolate covered strawberries yes
have some lavender oil so you can i want
the flowers to be exactly like how kim
kardashian did it with kanye all over
the floor and i want kenny g to be
playing that i don't like that
there's bound there's bound to be a
thorn in there there's gotta be some
beasts lying around yeah i have a
question what would yours be then
the first one obviously was my real one
but you know a perfect weekend getaway
i think yeah flight is out for me we're
gonna drive somewhere
everyone's saying joshua tree i think
maybe joshua tree joshua tree rent a
really cool airbnb because i heard the
houses they're really cool you like bugs
and
woodsy stuff
i think it would be different and
interesting because
where else would you go i'm just not
about it i think that's what i would do
that's really cozy and romantic and
under the stars and you could have a
fire
and you could
you know
put on body paint and and do some dances
i don't know oh you know would be better
that's what i think maybe the best i
think we could both agree if it was a
week and getaway
cabo
a really fun time in cabo right right
still have to fly though yeah but that's
like a short flight i can look really
cute on short flight yeah but then you
have to get like bikini bonnie ronnie oh
that's fair it's a lot of work if you
guys were extra aware of the little
intro song that we have brought back
because so many people missed it i know
and honestly i kind of missed it too so
i'm really happy that it's back we got
the og song so yeah i would just like to
mention that and thank you guys so much
for tuning in this week we had the best
time and i hope you guys do the erotic
blueprint and tell us what your results
were so remember message us on that
we'll see you next tuesday bye
[Music]